under the pressure of crushing economic
sanctions russia is straining to play
its own intimidation game
this time they're threatening to take
the international space station out of
orbit and hurdle it down to earth
[Music]
how could they make good on this absurd
threat
what places would be in danger of impact
and
what would this all mean for the future
of space exploration
this is what if and here's what would
happen if russia crashed the
international space station
the iss orbits above the earth's surface
at an altitude of about 400 kilometers
from end to end the largest spacecraft
ever built is
109 meters
that means including its solar panels it
stretches the length of an entire
football field and it has the volume of
a five-bedroom house to accommodate as
many as eleven astronauts if needed
the station wouldn't exist if it weren't
for the 15 nations that joined forces to
build and use it
five different space agencies were
involved in getting all the nodes and
modules of the station off the ground
and into orbit
but its days in orbit could be numbered
dmitri ragozan director general of
roscosmos posted a series of tweets that
stated in part
if you block cooperation with us
who will save the iss from an
uncontrolled d-orbit that falls into the
united states or europe
there is also the option of dropping the
500-ton structure to india and china
could russia really hijack the iss and
turn it into a falling death trap
bombastic as it sounds the threat is not
completely far-fetched
russia could even manage to do it
without the cooperation of the
cosmonauts currently on board the
station
right now significant changes to the
orbital pattern of the iss can't be done
without the cooperation of roscosmos
these adjustments can be made by the
thrusters of two unmanned russian
progress supply ships
or a zvezda service module
without these necessary adjustments to
orbit
the iss would be left to fend for itself
this would put the station and the
cosmonauts on board at risk of a
dangerous collision with large amounts
of debris currently orbiting the planet
on the other hand the thrusters on these
devices primarily used for delivering
supplies and fuel or making repairs
could be controlled to send the iss out
of orbit
but surely the russians wouldn't
endanger the lives of its own cosmonauts
right
well think again
in november of 2021
russia tested an anti-satellite missile
on one of its own satellites
this threatened the safety of all iss
crew members who had to prepare for
collisions with the massive amounts of
debris generated by the explosion
so with your doubts cast aside
now would be a good time to look up
spot anything bright moving across the
sky and getting bigger
you could easily think that this is just
a comet streaking across the sky with
its tail of colorful gas trailing behind
it
you'd be stunned by the sheer beauty of
this site until you realize that it's
the iss heading right toward you
the iss passes over india china the
united states and much of europe
so it would be at a high risk of impact
in many parts of the globe
however russia itself wouldn't have any
reason to worry about self-inflicted
damage in this case
the station is made from tough durable
materials like dense titanium kevlar and
high-grade steel
but entering the atmosphere the intense
heat and pressure could break it apart
and as that gets underway you'd see
fiery explosions of glitter and bright
light this would be both beautiful and a
positive sign
the station breaking into smaller pieces
could mean more impact sites but the
impacts would all be significantly less
severe than if it remained intact
imagine cities like los angeles london
or hong kong taking a direct hit from a
completely intact space station
it would leave a crater almost 1300
meters wide
and 470 meters deep
anyone close to the impact area would be
killed or severely burned in the ensuing
explosive firebomb
and the impact itself could trigger a
magnitude 6 earthquake
depending on where the strike occurred
you'd see tens of thousands of people or
more die
millions could be severely injured or
displaced by the destruction
if all this unfolded it would damage the
relationships between many space
agencies
and losing our only space laboratory
currently in orbit would certainly be a
significant setback to the future of
space exploration
but if there's one silver lining
this kind of maneuver could take several
years to unfold
hopefully this would give nasa and other
agencies enough time to react
maybe they'd be able to guide it
directly into the spacecraft cemetery
located in point nemo the furthest
region from land on earth
this would be just a little earlier than
expected as the iss is set to retire and
plunge to this spot in 2031.
using the iss as a weapon would be a
disastrous event that could endanger
millions of lives
but so would launching a nuke
and
that's a story
for
another what if
[Music]